Traduttore: Giovanni Scoletta
Revisore: Federico Sangati
Io sono un'educatrice che lavora
nell'ambito dell'autismo.
Autismo: ma che cos'è?
Tutti siamo un po' autistici.
Tutti abbiamo dei momenti in cui
ci estraniamo dalla realtà,
in cui facciamo dei gesti ripetitivi,
come per esempio spostare
una ciocca di capelli
senza neppure accorgercene.
Per alcune persone
questo estraniarsi dal mondo
è una condizione perenne,
così come la ripetizione di gesti
che diventa una necessità
per mantenere un equilibrio.
La variabilità di comportamenti
nell'autismo è molto grande.
Io lavoro appunto
con questi ragazzi autistici
e io vedo come ci sono
dei bambini che non parlano.
Mi ci è voluto più di un anno
per riuscire a fargli dire
anche solo una parola come "ciao".
Invece altri bambini parlano
però pronunciano delle parole staccate
che sono difficili da comprendere
e da riuscire a capire
che cosa cosa mi vogliono dire.
Altri ancora invece parlano,
la loro comunicazione è molto fluente
però solo per alcuni argomenti
di loro interesse.
Quindi il nostro lavoro educativo
è molto difficile
perché ci dobbiamo adattare
ad ogni singolo bambino
e ad ogni richiesta
che questo bambino ci fa.
E dobbiamo quindi tenere sempre presente
che ogni individuo è un caso a sé.
E anche due bambini
che per esempio parlano
con lo stesso numero di parole,
il nostro comportamento
che adottiamo con un ragazzo,
con un altro deve essere
completamente diverso.
Quindi siamo costantemente in gioco,
costantemente ci troviamo in difficoltà,
certe volte anche a lavorare con loro.
E le tecnologie, secondo noi,
ci possono essere molto d'aiuto.
Per esempio, Massimo,
parlaci di questo!
Si!
Progettare tecnologie per l'autismo
è particolarmente complicato
perché si rischia di fare degli strumenti
poco flessibili e alla fine inutili.
Nell'osservare come i terapisti,
come Cristina,
lavorano con i ragazzi autistici,
abbiamo notato come siano eccezionali
ad adattare ogni singola attività
alle specifiche caratteristiche
di ogni bambino.
E lo strumento principe per fare questo
è spesso, se non sempre, la carta.
La carta è estremamente flessibile
perché la si può disegnare,
si può colorare, si può scrivere,
ma si puote anche ritagliare,
fotocopiare e così via.
Con la carta si può raccontare,
si può far raccontare delle storie,
si può chiedere,
si possono coinvolgere i ragazzi
nel chiedere indicazioni
e nel dare spiegazioni.
All'inizio pensavamo di prendere
alcune di queste attività
e portarle sul computer o sul tablet,
ma poi ci siamo chiesti:
"Ma perché sostituire uno strumento
che già funziona benissimo,
come la carta,
e invece non usare la tecnologia
per arricchire la carta,
per poter fare qualcosa che oggi
sulla carta non si può mettere?"
Verba volant.
Scripta manent.
Facciamo in modo che anche verba manent.
Quello che abbiamo provato a fare
è fare in modo che ogni foglio di carta
sia un registratore,
cioè sia possibile su ogni foglio di carta
registrare la propria voce
e riascoltarla in seguito.
Ad esempio,
volevo farvi vedere un foglio
che ha disegnato mia figlia Matilda
e che ha raccontato
qualche giorno fa,
sul primo video.
"Questo è mio papà
che corre nei prati."
Si sente male.
Non si sente.
Si può farlo ripartire?
"Questo è il mio papà
che corre nei prati."
Ok.
La registrazione, ovviamente,
non è fisicamente sul foglio,
è sul computer
che però non si vede.
Si sente ma non si vede,
perché è nascosto sotto il tavolo.
Quello che succede è che la lampada
ha una piccola telecamera
ed è in grado di dare un nome
ad ogni singolo foglio.
In questo modo,
ad ogni foglio viene associata
una registrazione
che rimarrà associata al foglio.
Nello stesso modo, come vediamo
adesso nel secondo video,
si può registrare
sempre usando questi strumenti
che assomigliano
a quelli del videoregistratore.
Possiamo far partire il secondo video.
"C'è un libro sul tavolo".
Abbiamo fatto sparire il computer
e abbiamo trasformato
ogni foglio di carta in un registratore.
Queste erano le nostre idee
come "technology".
Cristina, ci racconti
cosa è successo, poi, quando
li avete davvero usati
con i bambini affetti da autismo?
Sì, Massimo, come tu ben sai
io lavoro presso l'ospedale
San Camillo di Torino.
Al San Camillo la nostra prassi educativa
è quella di utilizzare,
come dicevi tu,
il foglio per scrivere, per colorare,
per attaccarci degli oggetti.
Noi, ancora prima
di venire a conoscenza della lampada,
abbiamo utilizzato, coi nostri ragazzi,
un registratore
su cui far registrare
la voce ad un ragazzo
per poi, in un secondo momento,
farla riascoltare ad un compagno
non presente in quel momento.
Vi vorrei parlare nello specifico
di questo ragazzo, Mario.
Il nome è un nome di fantasia,
anche se quello che
poi vi racconto è successo realmente.
Nel momento in cui io gli ho chiesto
di registrare, di descrivere
che cosa vedeva sul foglio,
lui era molto distratto,
pronunciava delle parole distaccate,
quasi che non si capivano.
"Mario, che cosa c'è sul foglio?"
"Pentola, piatto, forchetta..."
"Ma... hai detto tutto?"
"Sì".
Abbiamo poi allora provato a riascoltare
con lui la registrazione.
"Mario, ma...
sei sicuro di aver detto tutto?"
"Dove sono gli oggetti?"
"Lì".
"Ma lì dove?"
"Se non lo spieghi, poi il tuo compagno
come fa a capire?"
Sono quindi state necessarie
numerose ripetizioni prima di riuscire,
finalmente, a far descrivere
a Mario tutto correttamente.
In un secondo momento
siamo poi entrati a conoscenza
di questo strumento,
della lampada,
e abbiamo deciso di provare
a utilizzarlo con i nostri ragazzi.
Ci siamo subito resi conto di come
il loro approccio
con questo strumento era diverso.
Si sono accorti che nella stanza
c'era questa lampada.
Hanno subito notato,
perché loro sono sì nel loro mondo,
ma si accorgono
quando c'è qualcosa di diverso,
che questa lampada
al posto della lampadina
aveva una telecamera.
Si sono ancora più incuriositi
quado io gli ho detto
che quella era una lampada magica
in grado di catturare la loro voce
per poi fargliela riascoltare.
E quindi abbiamo riprovato a fare
lo stesso esercizio di prima
sempre con questo ragazzo, Mario,
ed era totalmente diverso.
"Mario, che cosa c'è sul foglio?"
"Una pentola sui fornelli
e un piatto sul tavolo".
Abbiamo poi riascoltato
con lui la registrazione
e lui in quel momento,
a differenza di prima,
era molto attento.
Guardava questa lampada,
sorrideva nell'ascoltare
la sua voce provenire da lì.
Diceva: "Com'è possibile questo?"
Le volte successive siamo riusciti
a ripetere tutto correttamente
senza che io
dovessi poi intervenire per aiutarlo.
Quindi, in conclusione,
questo per noi è stato veramente utile
e bello, anche per i ragazzi,
perché sono riusciti a superare
questi loro deficit comunicativi
e riuscire quasi a entrare
in empatia con questa lampada.
Anche per noi educatori
è stato assolutamente bellissimo
perché ci ha permesso
di concentrarci sul foglio di carta
dimenticandoci un po'
quella che è la registrazione.
Questo è quello che è stato per noi.
Invece per te, Massimo?
Sì, anche per noi
è stato molto interessante.
Per noi la lampada è un esempio
di un nuovo modo
di costruire la tecnologia:
una tecnologia che sparisce
nel senso che non appare,
non resta in evidenza.
Vorremmo fare in modo che le persone
non debbano cambiare
il loro modo di lavorare
se funziona bene
perché c'è una tecnologia.
Ma, viceversa, che la tecnologia,
restando dietro o sotto al tavolo,
aiuti a valorizzare, ad arricchire,
a rendere più importante
il ruolo delle persone
e delle relazioni tra le persone.
E come diceva Cristina all'inizio,
in fin dei conti
siamo tutti un po' autistici.
Forse la tecnologia,
questo tipo di tecnologia,
nel futuro, ci aiuterà tutti
ad esserlo un po' meno.
Grazie!
(Applausi)